[Music]
what is data science let's start with
some of the common definitions that's
doing the rounds some say that data
science is a powerful new approach for
making discoveries from data others term
it as an automated way to analyze
enormous amounts of data and extract
information from it still others refer
to it as a new discipline which combines
aspects of Statistics mathematics
programming and visualization to gain
insights now that you have looked at
some of its definitions let's learn more
about data science when domain expertise
and the scientific methods are combined
with technology we get data science
which enables one to find solutions for
existing problems
let's look at each of the components of
data science separately the first
component is domain expertise and
scientific methods data scientists
should also be domain experts as they
need to have a passion for data and
discover the right patterns in them
traditionally domain experts like
scientists and statisticians collected
and analyzed data in a laboratory setup
or a controlled environment
the data was then subject to relevant
laws or mathematical and statistical
models to analyze the data set and
derive relevant information from it
for instance they use the models to
calculate the mean median mode standard
deviation and so on of a data set it
helped them test their hypothesis or
create a new one in the next slide we
will see how data science technology has
now made this process faster and more
efficient but before we do that let's
understand the different types of data
analysis an important aspect of data
science data analysis can either be
descriptive where when studies a data
set to explain what happened or be
predictive where one creates a model
based on existing information to predict
the outcome and behavior it can also be
prescriptive for one suggest the action
to be taken in a given situation using
the collected information we now have
access to tools and techniques that
process data and extract the information
we need for instance there are data
processing tools for data wrangling we
have new and flexible programming
languages that are more efficient and
easier to use
with the creation of operating systems
that support multiple OS platforms it's
now easier to integrate systems and
process Big Data application designs and
extensive software libraries helped
develop more robust scalable and
data-driven applications data scientists
use these technologies to build data
models and run them in an automated
fashion to predict the outcome
efficiently this is called machine
learning which helps provide insights
into the underlying data they can also
use data science technology to
manipulate data
extra--
information from it and use it to build
tools applications and services but
technological skills and domain
expertise alone without the right
mathematical and statistical knowledge
might lead data scientists to find
incorrect patterns and convey the wrong
information now that you have learned
what data science is it will be easier
to understand what a data scientist does
data scientists start with a question or
a business problem then they use data
acquisition to collect data sets from
the real world the process of data
wrangling is implemented with data tools
and modern technologies that include
data cleansing data manipulation data
discovery and data pattern
identification the next step is to
create and train models for machine
learning they then design mathematical
or statistical models after designing a
data model it's represented using data
visualization techniques the next task
is to prepare a data report after the
report is prepared they finally create
data products and services let us now
look at the various skills a data
scientist should have data scientists
should ask the right questions for which
they need domain expertise the curiosity
to learn and create concepts and the
ability to communicate questions
effectively to domain experts data
scientists should think analytically to
understand the hidden patterns in a data
structure they should wrangle the data
by removing redundant and irrelevant
data collected from various sources
statistical thinking and the ability to
apply mathematical methods are important
traits for a data scientist data should
be visualized with graphics and a proper
storytelling to summarize and
communicate the analytical results to
the audience to get these skills they
should follow a distinct road map it's
important they adopt the required tools
and techniques like Python and its
libraries they should build projects
using real-world data sets that include
data gov NYC open data Gapminder and so
on they should also build data-driven
applications for digital services and
data products
scientists work with different types of
datasets for various purposes now that
big data is generated every second
through different media the role of data
science has become more important so you
need to know what Big Data is and how
you are connected to it to figure out a
way to make it work for you every time
you record your heartbeat through your
phone's biometric sensors post or tweet
on the social network create any blog or
website switch on your phone's GPS
network upload or view an image video or
audio in fact every time you log into
the Internet you are generating data
about yourself your preferences and your
lifestyle big data is a collection of
these and a lot more data that the world
is constantly creating in this age of
the Internet of Things or IOT big data
is a reality and a need big data is
usually referenced by three B's volume
velocity and variety volume refers to
the enormous amount of data generated
from various sources big data is also
characterized by velocity huge amounts
of data flow at a tremendous speed from
different devices sensors and
applications to deal with it an
efficient and timely data processing is
required variety is the third V of big
data because big data can be categorized
into different formats like structured
semi-structured and unstructured
structured data is usually referenced to
as our DBMS data which can be stored and
retrieved easily through SQL
semi structured data are usually in the
form of files like XML JSON documents
and no SQL database text files images
videos or multimedia content are
examples of unstructured data in short
big data is a very large information
database usually stored on distributed
systems or machines popularly referred
to as Hadoop clusters but to be able to
use this database we have to find a way
to extract the right information and
data patterns from it that's where data
science comes in data science helps to
build information
enterprise's hey want to become an
expert in Big Data then subscribe to the
simply learned channel and click here to
watch more such videos centered up and
get certified in Big Data click here